Ilmastonmuutos tarkoittaa kasvihuoneilmiön voimistumista.
Luonnollisessa kasvihuoneilmiössä osa maahan osuvasta auringon säteilystä jää
lämmittämään planeettaamme ja osa heijastuu takaisin avaruuteen.
Kasvihuonekaasut kuten hiilidioksidi, metaani ja dityppioksidi estävät lämmön
normaalia poistumista ilmakehästä avaruuteen, jolloin planeettamme lämpenee.
Ilmaston lämpeneminen ei ole samanlaista maapallon eri osissa ja ilmastonmuutos
aiheuttaa lämpenemisen lisäksi myös äärimmäisten sääilmiöiden lisääntymistä ja
voimistumista. Kasvihuonekaasuja joutuu ilmakehään erityisen paljon ihmisen
vaikuttaessa hiilen kiertokulkuun.
Luonnossa kasveihin ja muuhun eloperäiseen ainekseen sitoutunut hiili varastoituu
hitaasti maaperään. Ihminen vapauttaa fossiilisiin poltta-aineisiin,
eli kivihiileen, öljyyn, maakaasuun ja turpeeseen sitoutunutta hiiltä ilmakehään
polttamalla niitä eri tavoin.